at age 15 I decided to leave school I
just you know couldn't do any exam so I
was hopeless I never felt like a victim
I think in movies really helped me kind
of saved me from shame take this
obstacle and make it the reason to have
a big life I felt horrible growing up I
always felt on the outside it makes you
so emotional why is that we all have
these limiting beliefs that hold us back
from success in our lives we believe
that we can't go out and accomplish our
goals because of this one particular
reason that we feel is holding us back
or what I found with with a little bit
of a perspective shift a mindset shift
you can turn that negative living and
belief the thing that you thought was
holding you back and turn it into a
superpower that helps propel you forward
you can live life with no limits so
today we're going to look at the
dyslexia advantage when I was at school
I would look at a blackboard and I would
not understand anything on that
blackboard and at age 15 I decided to
leave school I just you know couldn't do
any exams I was hopeless when I went out
into the real world and I came across
things that I was interested in and I
think I could get a better grasp on it
than most people and because I was a
dyslexic I was also very good at finding
other really good people to surround
myself with good people who could
compensate for my weaknesses and and it
taught me to be a very good delegator
witch which is very important of your
running businesses and and and I think
you know the advice I give to mothers
who've got dyslexic children is you know
let them don't force them too hard on
the things they find the difficult but
they will exceed excel on on some other
areas and push them into those other
areas and and
and a lot of you know a lot of the most
successful people in the world were once
or are dyslexic from my 20s I started
talking about the fact that you know
that I've discovered that it was
dyslexic and and I did it on purpose
because I think it's important for other
you know especially young kids who've
been told that they're dyslexic to see
that you know the successful people you
know can get through it and and that you
know if they follow their particular
dreams they follow what they're good at
that you know that they could be they
can be even more successful at what
they're good at than others so and there
are so many people like myself who have
excelled in their you know individual
professions who have been dyslexic so I
think it I think it really I think it's
really important that you know people
who are dyslexic get get out and talk
about it yeah I mean I am dyslexic and
and therefore I think I've been very
good at keeping things simple because
you know as a dyslexic I need to need
things to be simple for myself and
therefore virgin I think you know when
we launched a financial service company
or a bank you know we do not use jargon
it's everything is very clear-cut very
simple and and I think people you know
people have an affinity to the Virgin
brand because we don't you know we don't
talk above them or talk down to them
as having been dyslexic for my entire
life and which explained a lot of things
it was like the last puzzle part in a
tremendous mystery that I've kept to
myself all these years that basically
started with just things that happen
when you're a kid in school and you're a
slow reader
yeah and in my case I was actually um
enabled to read for for at least two
years I was two years behind the rest of
my class and of course I went through
what everybody goes through is teasing
yeah and I had to go through that for a
long time and so the teasing you know
led to a lot of other problems I was
having in school but it all stemmed from
the fact that I was embarrassed to stand
up in front of the class and and and and
and read but I never felt like a victim
that was the important thing I never
felt like a victim I think movies really
helped me kind of save me from shame
from from guilt from putting it on
myself when it wasn't really you know
you know my own burden it wasn't my
burden and I think making movies was my
Great Escape that's really how I was
able to get away from all of that and
you think that can kind of show through
your movies you show and like how you
felt or you know just what you felt
about the world or what you felt about
people teasing you I guess or what you
were going through not really my first
movies didn't do that my first movies
were just basically imitations in movies
I was going out to theaters to see so
they were pure you know genre movies you
know war movies Western science fiction
and and there were no statements I made
no statement I'm talking about my eight
millimeter movies I'm going way back
before I became a director and and I'm
just saying that in in in light of
feeling a little bit like an outsider
movies made me feel inside my own
skillset and the other thing is I'm in a
business right now we're reading is very
important you know it's going to it's of
critical importance to me that I read
books and scripts and and and and so
I've been able to overcompensate and I
just basically with the note with never
feeling ashamed of myself will take you
know two hours and 45 minutes to three
hours to read a 120 pages takes me about
two hours 45 minutes to read
what most people can read in about an
hour and 10 minutes and I just know I'm
still slow at reading but I've learned
to adjust I just don't I read often but
I'm very here's a great thing also I
have great comprehension in what I read
because I do read slowly I retain almost
everything I read
I don't just skip over things yeah and
I'm able to appreciate the writing I'm
able to kind of really savor good
writing because I really take my time
going through a book or a script if you
had any advice to get for young kids who
have dyslexia and who are just finding
out what they're going through now what
would you tell them just that it's more
common than you could imagine and that
you're not alone and that there are ways
to accelerate your reading skills to
accelerate your comprehension and there
are ways to deal with it it's not an
incurable thing it's something you're
going to have the rest of your life but
you can sort of you know dart between
the raindrops to get where you want to
go and it will not hold you back do you
think your dyslexia got you to where you
are today I'm sure it had a large a
large hand in it yeah and the fact that
since I was born I've always known I
want to pretend to put myself in other
time periods to be able to pretend to be
another species I mean that stuff to me
is interesting and and it helps my mind
excellent yeah it's our way of escaping
the real life and I guess normal people
can't really do that they have a harder
time I think they have a very hard time
and for that I got you to know I think
the advantage is my brain sees and puts
information in my head differently
mm-hmm sometimes more interestingly I
think then then if I saw like everyone
else I think it's less challenging now
because we have some idea about it
but I think the challenge will always be
how we see ourselves not as folks with a
handicap but folks with an interesting
perspective on everything or just hold
on to your dreams and you know never
ever think that you're not good enough
or that you're stupid you know never let
anyone tell you that you're stupid or
that you know you're not capable because
it's a human issue isn't it it's like
it's it's it's mostly a human issue you
know we are we're all the same we're all
equal and you know and we deserve a shot
and I would just say you know take take
this obstacle and make it the reason to
have a big life because if you can climb
and if you can overcome that obstacle
you're going to be that much further
ahead than anyone else because it takes
having obstacles to you know to learn
and grow and be better you know it's
like if it was smooth plane sailing you
know what do you what do you know what
do you become if you're a straight-a
student maybe maybe that's great maybe
I'm sure there are plenty of straight-a
students who end up smoking pot take a
nap you're not I mean insane but but the
obstacle the the mountain that is that
the challenge of climbing that dyslexia
is is something that you can make your
own and make it a reason to be a winner
in life found out that you had what you
had to slice it but way later on in your
life right I found out when I was 31
you know what inspired me here's the
thing I felt horrible growing up I
always felt on the outside I always felt
like I was stupid like I couldn't figure
out concepts and what what I my my
message is you have greatness in you not
one of the children sitting here does
not have greatness in them and it is
really important that they know that and
that school is the law
maybe school is difficult but when you
get out you soar like an eagle it is not
the money it's just the way you see the
child is an individual and and what it
is they need and it's not a matter of
coddling it's not a matter of spoiling
but if a herd child to me is a powerful
child if a child feels like somebody is
paying attention they feel differently
about themselves and that's just the
truth so let me just say to all the
children that are listening every one of
you is powerful and school does not
define you you define yourself I'm not
kidding you're wonderful
what was it like being here and not
being the smartest kid in the class you
know we didn't call it dick selects the
event it was called smarten up it's not
not smarten up Jay was dyslexic and you
know that a lot of his time in the
principal's office
for pulling pranks or laying rubber in
the parking lot and I think his parents
were very concerned about what was going
to happen to him you know I had a
wonderful teacher in English teaching me
they mrs. Hawkes she said you know I
always see telling stories and making
jokes why don't you take my creative
writing class and I'll give you a credit
in English for that and you write some
of these stories down maybe good reading
to the class did that change you at all
yeah because it was the first time in my
life I actually focused on something I
was when I would do homework would be
okay 16 times fine what's that a fly oh
you know I mean I would just never focus
on anything so that was the first time
my life I think I really focused on
something he turned out to be the famous
one the rich one the and he and I think
he did that because he worked so hard
you
did they try and encourage you to be
better or did they just sweep you to the
side now I went into special needs
classes which is about four kids that
went up had special extra classes and
stuff and yeah my teachers were lovely
but I don't think that we were as
strategically as advanced as we are now
I think we're much better at it now but
also we didn't recognize dyslexia it was
like an on/off button you're even
dyslexic and you had to literally be
looking through 2 inch glasses or you
know and I think you know now we know as
many forms of it and and and I don't
think I'm deeply held back by dyslexia
but I mean undoubtably I've got it but
you know I think I think I was given all
the support for the time and it just
wasn't my place to shine really I had a
kid come up to me the other day and he
can't sometimes you read about stuff
like this we don't exist that it's a
real emotion and this kid must have been
about 10 and he came up to me and said I
heard you're dyslexic I said yes I am
and he said have you ever felt that
you're worth nothing and I'm like no why
why do you think do you feel that and
he's like yeah that's the stage when you
got a start worrying because it doesn't
you know but being dyslexic or or having
any special needs is not an excuse or a
reason for you to not prosper it's just
you're not going to be good at the
predictable things but you know I mean
there's wonderful people in business and
architecture and art and music that have
had learning difficulties and but I
think what that kid was tapping into is
is that every single one of us need to
feel like we're good at something
otherwise we feel like you know and he
obviously did so I had a little pep talk
with him anyway for sort of 10 10
minutes and hopefully hopefully it made
a difference I told him to come and see
me in he was 16 I said I'll give you a
job
really what I'm talking about
self-esteem and that you know that can
be relevant to anyone regardless of
dyslexia or not really
after I started to talk about this being
dyslexic and as I researched it I have
to really look at it and say it's an
asset um and I think the asset is that
when I had to read something I had to
read it five times when you know I got
saw the opportunity of co-op to go to
school one week and work the other I
went to work I always just visualized
and concentrate on things because maybe
the theory is we're not getting you know
dyslexics don't get caught up reading
books and reading how it should be done
and go out and execute how it should be
done right and it's funny out you know I
walk in a room especially I'll do
speaking game over 5,000 people I say
how many people in here are dyslexic
nobody four people raised their hand
right and it's usually the CEOs and very
very powerful people that raised their
hands but people that work within
environments their shame and they're
afraid and they don't say and then I
start to give them the stats about Will
Smith and Tom Cruise and myself and the
four sharks and then also in every way
there were dyslexic raising their hand
so but I just want obviously to bring
this awareness to people and it's
nothing to be ashamed of absolutely not
and uh you know we want to make sure
that people get you know got tested if
they feel that you know there's a
challenge as a learning challenge
okay so dyslexia you might have this and
teachers you might see kids who might be
suffering from this you can look this
stuff at you can find that but you can
get help and stuff gets better in life
so if you're having a tough time of it
now don't worry about it too much but
reach out talk to parents talk to
friends talk to teachers talk to
everyone and there's a hashtag you can
look this up then to the vote alone you
know a dyslexic you know a dyslexic now
you have to stay off the spell that they
have to spell know with a this is tricky
it should just be ping it should be
hashtag King but it's ashtag you know it
is lecture anyway there's the hashtag
put that in and you win a sausage and
you can get your like that and stuff
will come up yes stuff will come up on
that which will help you there it is
things can get better and will get
better if you have to take action upon
it action do things to make this change
and then you can be a crazy person like
me and have painted fingernails and
living talking with the words that were
the problem in the spelling and you'd be
given this thing which looks like a
negative but you could turn it into a
positive that's my message to you so
take this stick it in your pipe and
smoke it
thank you goodbye you're dyslexic yes
you learned that at a really a pretty
young age I was dyslexic and very very
much so it was very challenging for me I
couldn't read in early ages and it
really affects her your reading score it
gets you pushed back but there was a
woman named Marjorie garlic who's very
famous out of a university McGill with
Sam Rabinovich and I became part of an
experimental class they were testing an
idea at the time and it was my mother
that got me in that class she kind of
made sure that I got in there somehow
and I thank her so much for it their
thesis went like this you feel so weird
when you're dyslexic because and I can
still do this I can read upside down I
can read in a mirror and what Marjorie
said was look this is not a fault you
have a superpower
and when you're that young you buy into
that it gives you the confidence you
need and that's what occurred to me she
gave me that confidence and that carried
you a long way yeah it makes you so
emotional why is that well excuse me I
just I think of those days
I think people only see your hard shell
yeah and they probably think that you
never ran into challenges like that
they were very tough times because I was
I was really wondering if I was ever
going to make it
I was it was you know those were very
tough times I was failing there was a
lot of panic in my own family my
teachers weren't sure and I knew it was
a it was I was very lucky I was very
lucky and I meet lots of dyslexic people
today and I give them encouragement
because it's it is a superpower thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what you
thought of this video it's part of a new
series that I'm thinking about creating
called No Limits where we look at
limiting beliefs that people have around
certain issues that they feel a holding
themselves back and then showcasing
people who have those same issues and
yet go on to achieve massive success so
this one looked at dyslexia and we're
potentially looking at looking at other
issues in the future so let me know what
you think should we continue this series
what did you think about this one leave
it down the comments below I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
you
I always tell the sexist I talk to that
it dis lecture is actually a gift
because it gives you talents that other
people don't have it's now very clear
that dyslexics excel at some kinds of of
occupations for instance there are more
artists or dyslexics that you expect
there are more architects who than you'd
expect there are more entrepreneurs than
you'd expect there are more engineers
than you'd expect now all those things
have a something in common that is to
say it means you have to have a holistic
outlook on life rather than being good
at sequential things reading requires
sequencing sequencing the letters and
the words and making sure you know where
they are in the right order
whereas artists require really to see a
whole scene and see how all the bits fit
together now dyslexics are much better
at that than they are at these
sequential things be clear that there
are more dyslexic 'some um artists
architects etc but the it's often argued
that that is because people who are
dyslexic about it reading and therefore
they are diverted away from things that
demand a lot of reading into things like
artists being an artistic cetera and but
the balance of evidence now suggests
that actually dyslexics are not just
forced into these kinds of pursuits but
they are actually more talented in them
and you can test that in the lab by
testing things like their ability to see
spot figures in a cluttered scenery or
their ability to discriminate colors a
lot of what we call holistic kinds of
visual spatial tasks dyslexics are
better at and that's absolutely clear so
that suggests very strongly that they do
have a superior talents that's only to
be expected
actually from a genetic point of your
evolutionary point of view the fact is
that dyslexia is extremely common but
10% of people have it particularly boys
that means that there must be
compensating advantage because if it was
all disadvantage that gene or genes we
now though at least know there's at
least 7 genes involved those genes would
have disappeared because they you know
what one of the things we know is that
many dyslexics have poor motion
discriminate a poor ability to pick up
motion and if you had a really serious
deficit in that regard you wouldn't see
the oncoming saber-toothed tiger and you
wouldn't live to procreate your genes so
it's quite clear there must be some
balancing advantage of being dyslexic
and then it's quite clear from what I've
just said that it is this holistic
talent this ability to see things in the
round that dyslexics have much more than
ordinary readers well I always tell
dyslexia sigh talk to that it dyslexia
is actually a gift because it gives you
talents that other people don't have and
I'm sure that that both things are true
that is to say and children who are
dyslexic tend to take up pursuits that
don't demand too much reading I would
anyway if I couldn't read them in it's
very very frustrating to be trying to
read a book and not be able to when your
peers can do so so you tend to do the
things you're good at and you're good at
these things that require holistic
vision spatial abilities and as we I
have just said we actually find that
dyslexics are very good at those kind of
pursuits so it's a combination the two
it's both the the ability to see things
in the round and also
and the fact that people odd are driven
towards those sort of pursuits because
they're not very good at reading
nobody says they're in opposition they
actually are happy marriage I would say
first dyslexics I met when I was first
introduced to the whole subject was
somebody who was a first Wrangler senior
Wrangler at and at Cambridge I have an
extremely good mathematician came first
in the math tripod and he was extremely
dyslexic and when I discussed it with
him he said well the thing was that he
was really bad at things like arithmetic
and adding and subtracting numbers but
as soon as he began to see there were
patterns in in mathematics he could see
patterns that other people couldn't and
Einstein said the same that he saw
things in pictures he didn't he couldn't
work it out sequentially and Einstein's
a well-known dyslexic it was a
well-known mistake well I'm sure you're
right because one of the things and this
has never actually been published but
one of the things I observed in working
with a primary school teacher was that
the dyslexic children were remarkably
good at drawing 3-dimensional objects
because most children say well a
three-dimensional object looks like this
and therefore they draw let's say the
top and then they don't know what to do
about the bits underneath whereas a
dyslexic we'll see how it actually looks
not how it should look and so they get
it right it's noticeable there are many
dyslexics among architects and the
reason probably is is that architects
need to be able to visualize how their
buildings are going to look when they're
completely built and it's very difficult
for most people to see that from plans
for instance flat plans on a piece of
paper but dyslexics are notoriously good
at seeing things in three dimensions or
and extrapolating from
dimensions into three dimensions because
of this holistic ability they have
Richard Rogers the famous architect who
is himself dyslexic says that he prefers
to have dyslexics in his drawing office
or in his architects office because they
could visualize how a building's going
to look and he needs that to be able to
know that the buildings can look Oh as
he wanted to this is highly
controversial but there seems to be
evidence that dyslexics are have more
activation of the parts of brain that
are known to be important for creativity
and so in functional magnetic resonance
imaging experiments where you get
dyslexics compared with good readers to
exhibit creativity there's a thing
called the Torrance tests of creativity
for instance you could show that there's
more or some people have shown that
there's more activation in a particular
part of the brain than this this part of
the brain in the frontal lobe and
there's more activation of that area in
dyslexics particularly in the left
hemisphere and then in good readers of
that correlates with their better
creativity this means being able to
sequence things in time sequence your
life as it were and there are
notoriously bad it dyslexics I've dealt
with you know no tourists who fail to
turn up on time or turn up two hours
earlier that sort of thing because they
don't have that absolutely embedded
sequencing style that most of us get
through education early in life but that
has it's good side as well because it
means that they are open to new
suggestions new ideas and that's
probably one of the things that
contributes to their artistic talents
another aspect of this is because they
have such bad time trying to learn to
read if they survive their schooling
they will have developed means of
getting over this plus a great deal of
determinate
yeah one of the things I'm convinced
that explains why I want among
entrepreneurs dyslexic so 10 times
over-represented than you'd expect
and it's because through the knocks of
life particularly during education
they've had to become very resilient
they've made lots of mistakes and
they've had to work way out ways around
these mistakes and as a consequence they
are extremely determined and successful
because they don't give up